see my Fest is a feeling the euphoric
moment of finally seeing their favorite
artists sing that song
this is the International Country Music
Fanfare held every June here in
Nashville
[Applause]
everybody just felt like oh this is
going to be the greatest thing ever and
it was it's good to be here thanks a lot
for coming out my first experience was
as a fan I want you to know that three
years ago I sat in that section I filter
every decision I make as an artist
through my fan lens
fans come from foreign wise kind of like
mecca for country music it's redneck
Hollywood
well CMA fast back in my day was called
Fanfare we would stand there in our hair
and makeup we signed every single
autograph my mom was so good about that
if you're a country music fan your
brains were blown
there was thousands of people online and
Garth signed for 23 straight hours
oh
yeah I'm gonna take my horse
[Music]
you see that camaraderie amongst the
artists happens on stage a lot of
collaborations happen when you get out
there and get to watch 65 000 people is
really powerful I am passing the Baton
to the next generation of greatness
I never forget the years it took to get
the headlining slot I've been coming
every single year since I was 14 years
old I moved here in a camper trailer
dreaming about being a part of CMA Fest
and dang it I am a part of it now
[Applause]
[Music]